so in real life you have the luxury of
being able to take the blindfolds off
while you're shooting but I was
wondering what was the most disorienting
thing about actually having that on
while you're making a movie nailing
blocking taking direction anything like
that avoiding the camera that was
probably don't yeah not running into
anything not hurting yourself and not
harming two children that you're
responsible you know that's the scary
part one yeah make sure that they're
okay I caught myself looking up be
rolled from the movie online and there's
a really long video of you shooting with
the two of them on the river and I still
can't believe what you went through to
make that sup yeah yeah you know what I
never would I never put them in harm's
way like I I always made sure that there
was an element or an ability to whip the
blindfold off I always knew where they
were my feet were always touching them
there was always something a part of my
body attached to them whether was if
we're shooting from the waist up it was
my hands it was my feet it was my feet
were wrapped around their feet there was
an they were tethered off there was
always an element of me adhered to those
kids to make sure that I knew where they
were I needed to return them to their
parents at the end of the day that was
Michael speaking of all that and so many
specifics being involved in that part of
the process I was reading that Suzanne
likes to let you be able to discover
things on set which feels like a very
fluid way of working so can you tell me
a little bit about working with her and
do you like that or do you find that to
be more challenging I person find that
to be the most liberating thing in the
world because just doing the work to
know the person is and then having the
freedom to explore everything about that
person in the space is always just an
amazing gift and so working with Suzanne
it was it was that you know it was a
gift so for sure you have to get very
comfortable with what you feel and have
to offer and not doubt it and just
continue on like after the scene is done
keep going keep going don't don't
self-doubt because then you see it and
then once you get used to it I think it
got easier and easier once we figured
out how she did it yeah yeah
how does she give you direction onset
especially when you're doing the
blindfolded material is it just about
sitting there and
I'm waiting for her to chime in she
allows you to hang yourself she allows
you all the rope in the world and the
angrier I would get like I wasn't
getting something and I would just
physically get into it out bounce a lot
to get because I was always out of
breath there was always a series of me
running back and forth before the scene
started just to get it and I would find
I would get so agitated and she wouldn't
say rolling I couldn't see anything I'm
like and then I'm dizzy because I've
been running and then I have to go and I
think all of that was on purpose I think
all of that was to get us to let go of
anything that might be a crutch or
something that we were a tool that we
would use that would have no bearing if
we were really in a situation sounds
exhausting but what's up producing great
results I lost five pounds one of my
favorite things about any movie any
scenario is one that inspires me to
challenge myself by putting myself in
that situation and wondering how I would
fare or in this how would you fare
terribly really I think I could survive
in most post apocalyptic scenarios
because I think I'm smart enough and
because like I run I can physically
carry myself in those types of things
taking away sight no I think you'd
surprise yourself I thought that too
until I worked with somebody that was
not sighted and showed me what abilities
we have that we never ever use that are
really profoundly helpful even though I
wear contacts and whenever I think of a
zombie apocalypse like my glasses get
stepped on I'm done I need my saline
solution I'm making my name
[Music]